Good evening, everybody.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe.
I'm the manager of a student
arts programs here at MIT.
I'm joined by my
associate, Theo Fields,
and we're really delighted to
introduce Julia Turnbull, who
is going to talk with
us about creating
a budget for the non-profit
track of the annual 15K
creative arts competition.
We'll talk a little bit
more at the end about some
of the other upcoming
opportunities, activities,
workshops, things like that.
But since Zoom
fatigue is real, I
don't want to belabor
the beginning.
So I think I'll turn it over
to Julia to do a quick intro,
and then we'll get
things rolling.
All right.
Thank you, Shannon,
and thank you, Theo.
So, first of all,
thank you for inviting
me to participate this
evening and asking
me to speak about this topic.
I think it's important.
And there are many
great resources
here at MIT and in
the community to help
you get started with this.
So, before we go ahead,
just a couple of things.
If you have questions, feel
free to put them in the chat.
Or you can raise your hand,
either with the Raise Your Hand
feature, or like the
old fashioned way
because I sometimes forget.
Just raised my
hand on the screen.
And also this is designed
to be conversational,
so please feel free to
just ask questions, share.
I know this is being recorded,
but I think, hopefully,
we can all kind of respect some
basic things of confidentiality
or just being respectful
of each other's questions
and comments and time, since
this is a learning environment.
So, and then one
other note, there
are lots of pictures in here.
They're all pictures that
I've taken at different points
in my travels.
Anyways, I didn't take them
from the internet or something
like that.
So anyways we will get started.
Let's see, too
many screens here.
All right.
Introductions.
So I, as Shannon introduced
me, my name is Julia.
I work in the Legatum Center for
development entrepreneurship.
And the Legatum Center
is situated within Sloan,
but actually started out under
the School of Architecture
and Planning several years ago.
So we are a center that
supports all MIT students
across the five
schools, as well as
faculty and staff who are
building inclusive economies
through innovation-driven
entrepreneurship.
So I've listed our website
as well as our Twitter
handle if you want to follow us.
If you want to go to the
website and scroll all the way
to the bottom, you can
sign up for our newsletter
and get some information
about things we're doing.
We've had a couple of fellows in
the past who have been involved
in the creative arts.
So you might recognize
Rebecca Huey in Roots Studio.
We've had several
from the School
of Architecture and Planning,
Kenfield Griffith, Ella
Peinovich, who started
a jewelry company.
So there's lots of space here,
many great opportunities.
All right, so that's
a little bit about me.
I actually started off my career
in international development
and global economics in
Mexico and learned a lot there
about artisans, also
people who are making
a living through arts-driven
entrepreneurship, as well
as people who are just
willing to try new things
and learn those as well.
In terms of my creative
skills, I don't have a lot.
But I do appreciate
bright colors.
And I'm actually in the process
now of redoing my condo.
So anybody has any great
suggestions for ideas
or paint colors or anything
like that, feel free to share.
All right.
We'll just go around.
Youyang, am I pronouncing
your name correctly?
Are you there?
No, OK.
It's OK I know it's dinner time.
He had some question
in the chat.
So I think maybe not answering
quickly, but in the chat.
I see.
OK.
You're not just a student.
You're also an entrepreneur.
You're an artisan.
You're involved in
the competition.
All right.
So we'll move along.
Feel free to add anything
to the conversation.
All right.
So Theo, do you want to do a
quick intro about, why don't we
all, we can all get to know
who we are, why we're here.
Yeah, definitely.
So I'm a first year MBA
student, coming from consulting
and then left that to
join Wayfair, trying
to get a little more of the
entrepreneurial or a startup
feel in a business.
And I'm considering doing some
kind of startup-related work
in the near future.
But I'm doing the E&I
track at Sloan right now.
Excellent.
Shannon, do you have
a favorite activity?
Oh, man.
Well, the intersection of sort
of passion and vocation for me
involves singing and being
a professor of music.
But when I'm not doing
that, I love glassblowing.
I'm terrible at it.
But my favorite non-professional
creative activity
is probably glassblowing.
Nice.
MIT is known for that.
I've heard.
I haven't made it
to the glass lab,
but when campus reopens
that's sort of priority one.
Yep, kind of a blue pumpkin.
All right.
So one question I do have,
just for people to consider
if you're watching
this asynchronously,
is whether you have
a hybrid model.
So the things that
we're talking about here
might apply to the non-profit
side of your business model.
And if you have a hybrid
model, hopefully you'll
find some
complementarities, I think
with the workshop that's
coming up on Wednesday, right,
for profit budgeting.
OK.
So you'll actually be joining
these two themes together.
And the Legatum Center,
we do have some case
studies on hybrid
business models, which
go beyond budgeting, but if
you're interested, reach out
and we can share those with you.
All right.
So just some things
we're going to cover
in the session, just the
basics of building a budget,
why it's important, and
what you should include.
And then as you go
into fundraising,
your budget will help you
prepare for fundraising.
So we'll talk about
some considerations
you might want to take
into account, as you start
to undertake that process.
And then, if we
have time, maybe we
can go over building a budget
and some fundraising tips,
if anybody has
anything particular
they wish to discuss.
And then we'll, of course, leave
time for any Q&A at the end.
Excellent.
Before we jump in, I think
I'm hearing a little feedback
from someone.
It might be me.
Hold on.
It's probably, it's my radiator.
Oh, that's what it is,
it does sound like that,
now that you mention it.
Yeah.
OK, is it better if I try
to move this computer?
By the way, totally fine.
I just wanted to, it was
coming to my attention.
But yeah, proceed.
Yeah, doing everything
remotely, these are the things
we encounter.
All right.
So what are some things
that come to mind
when you think about a budget?
Probably not like
these lovely walls
in Frida Kahlo's courtyard.
But there are a couple
of things you just
want to keep in mind generally.
So you want to keep in
mind categories, right,
so having a way to think
about how you organize
your financial information.
You might organize it
according to a project,
you might organize it according
to the type of expense.
So is it a salary?
Is it something physical,
like the space or the studio
you might be renting,
marketing expenses, which
can be tangible and intangible.
So we're now in this age
of everything is online,
so you're creating
digital posters
and all of those things.
But you have to think
about are you using Adobe?
Are you using a Mac product?
How are you creating that?
What is it costing you?
What are you getting,
maybe in kind or for free?
What are some
things that you may
be able to use as an MIT
student or a student that
are available to
you now, but you
would have to think about
how are you going to budget
and pay for those maybe
once you graduate,
or once you use up all of your
Amazon Web Services credits,
or those kinds of things.
So just start to
think about, as you're
building a budget, as
you're paying for things,
think about what are the
things that you absolutely
need to provide your
product or service,
and how much do they
cost, and how much
do they cost either
on an hourly basis
or on a per project
basis, right?
But start to think about,
you're a non-profit
but that doesn't mean
you're not sustainable.
And I think that's really
important to recognize,
that non-profit
organizations have missions.
But they are sustainable
organizations.
And they just have to
think and plan differently
for how you match the
costs or the expenses
that you incur with
the product or service
that you're delivering
to the market.
So I don't want building a
budget to be a dry topic.
I know it's not exciting.
I know that sometimes it's
something we don't want to do.
But I want you to
think of your budget
as a tool that supports
your mission and your work,
and not something that's
just another chore.
There are lots of
things that are chores.
But it's really
something that's going
to enable you to scale and
grow your impact in what you're
doing.
All right, so building
a budget, this
is going to be the first step in
creating an accurate financial
picture of your organization.
If you start to
build a budget, you
will find that it's
much easier to source
your other financial
statements, so
your income statement
or a balance sheet
once you start to have those
numbers, because then you
have an idea of how you're
allocating your resources,
and also what resources
you need to scale and grow.
And you're going to find
things will change over time.
You're going to see
where you have recurring
expenses that you could reduce.
So you might be renting
something, and, after a while,
you realize it makes
sense to purchase it.
Or you may realize that
a piece of equipment
becomes outdated quickly,
and it doesn't make sense
to purchase that
piece of equipment.
It actually makes sense
to rent it long term
or find a leasing model or
make sure you get a maintenance
program, because that's where
the real costs build up, right?
So information and
knowledge actually
become really critical tools in
making you a more sophisticated
entrepreneur, in
terms of how you're
maximizing your resources.
There's actually an
artisan, she knits hats.
She lives in Vermont.
Her name's Hannah.
And she has a blog called, Why
are these hats so expensive?
And she actually breaks down,
right, she takes the hat
and then she kind of takes
it apart and works backwards.
And she says, this is how
much yarn goes into the hat.
This is how much wool
I have to purchase.
This is how much dye I need.
And she really goes through all
of those unit economics costs,
and then says this is how I come
up with the price of the hat.
One thing that's
really important
is that she values her time.
So she's an artisan,
but she also
says this is actually
what it costs me.
This is what my time
is worth, and these
are what my living
expenses are, and she
factors all of those things
into the value of her time.
So I think that's one thing,
it's very easy, especially
for anyone who's a
student full-time,
to think of this as
a hobby or a project.
But you really want to
think of this, again,
going back to being a
sustainable organization,
your people are going to be
your most important assets,
including the founders,
especially the founders.
And so you want to make
sure that you're accurately
valuing your time.
And we'll talk about some
different ways to do that.
But that's one area I
think where people often
mis-underestimate
their expenses, right?
They don't value their time.
And then also as
you start to think
about what you
want to accomplish,
what you are
accomplishing, and what
you have to change to
get there, a budget
will actually help you realize,
OK, this isn't what we need.
Or you'll be able to
recognize seasonal patterns
in your income, and
how do you match
all of those things over time.
All right.
So the key, a
budget is, there are
going to be two sides, your
expenses and your income.
So, as I mentioned,
it's really important
to think about
everything that you
incur to produce your
product or service.
If you have a loom, that's a
recurring fixed expense, right?
So it doesn't
matter if you weave
10 rugs or 20 rugs in a month,
you've purchased the loom
and that's a sunk cost.
And then you're going
to have variable costs.
So if you're purchasing,
if you're making more rugs,
you're going to incur other
materials, the thread, the dye,
all of those different things.
Thinking about, if
you have anything
that changes seasonally in
terms of inputs or availability,
demand, especially I think
space in Kendall Square
is a huge one, right?
There's a seasonality to that.
So those are just some different
things you want to think about.
So I think really
understanding what
you're producing from
the beginning to the end,
and how that factors into
your next either sales cycle
or production cycle, or
whatever you're doing.
So I don't know if anyone here
is familiar with HubSpot's
flywheel.
So they talk about
the cycle of you're
going to basically attract
delight and then re-engage
your customer, right?
So you attract them,
you bring them in.
You delight them.
So they're like getting a
rug and then they discover,
Oh, there's something, when I
look at it from the other side
I see a completely
different pattern,
or the light looks different
in the morning than it does
in the afternoon, right?
And they're delighted
by these features.
And then you find ways
to re-engage them, right?
And so that's kind of the cycle
that you want to look for.
And you want to think
about that, again,
as you start to
build your budget.
What does that look like?
I mean, think about a lot of
other things that people buy,
so shoes and clothing and meals.
The things you buy on
Saturday when you go out
with your friends are
different from what
you get on Tuesday at lunch
when you're just in a hurry.
So you want to think about
all of these different things
and how they factor
into your expenses.
All right.
So as I mentioned, when
you're starting out,
I think that the easiest way
to think about your expenses
is in terms of categories.
And you can Google these things.
I mean this is a
pretty good list
of the different categories.
Workspace is often a big
one, administrative costs.
So those are all the things
you need to keep going.
G-Suite has a lot of free
things for non-profits,
hopefully you know that.
Web hosting, the same, you
can find varying degrees.
Things like snacks, if you're
buying snacks for your staff,
right?
I mean that's really common
in a lot of workspaces.
But these are small things
that people forget, especially
as they start to grow or think
about leaving the MIT nest.
But these are the things
that are actually important
and they add up.
Staff compensation, this is
one we talked about often.
You're a startup and maybe you
can't compensate people yet.
But find a way to approximate
the value of the time, right?
So if you have someone
who's in a managerial role,
then find out what a manager
in your same market is paid.
I mean you can do that
on an annual salary
and do all the math and
break down the hours, right?
But those are really good ways
to budget for your expense.
And then we'll talk
about recording
that back in, tracking that
as time that's donated.
And then we also talked
about, in some cases,
it makes sense to think about
program and project expenses.
So and this is common in
especially non-profits that
might have programs that are
funded by multiple donors,
right?
So you have to start to allocate
expenses to different programs.
And then you have to decide
50% of someone's salary
is coming from this
funder and 50% is coming
from another funder, right?
Or you may have
funders who say, I'm
really interested
in visual arts,
and you may have
others who say, I'm
really interested in
musical arts, right?
And you have to find ways
to make those things work.
And I think tracking these
expenses, especially expenses
that might be shared across
projects, is really important.
So once you have
your budget, you
can start to figure that
out, because the funders
for non-profits,
especially, are going
to be interested in
reporting and wanting to know
the impact of their dollars.
So.
yeah, just remember, staff
time is incredibly valuable
and don't discount
that, especially
as you're in a startup
kind of mode, right?
Any other comments,
thoughts, and these
are just some big
categories, but you
might find other categories
are better for your industry.
I think I really like
the way that you're
talking about really making
sure that you're cognizant,
even if you don't have
the financial outlay
capacities to pay
people for their time,
you've got to figure out like in
a perfect world, how much does
it cost to run this thing.
So you cannot over emphasize
enough the importance
of accounting for the snacks,
accounting for the unpaid labor
that should ideally turn into
paid labor when there's capital
for that.
So thank you for that.
All right.
So we go on.
All right, income.
So what do people think of when
they think of income, right?
It's money that comes in, right?
And this gets tricky.
So there's income,
which is everything
that comes into your venture.
So that's prize money,
grant funds, that volunteer,
that start-up, that
sweat equity, right?
Anything else that might
be donated, but also
think about what are the costs
of accessing those, right?
So you can enter
into prizes, you
can enter into competitions, you
can spend time writing grants,
but there are costs
associated with that.
And again it's time.
It's what you need to produce
high quality visual materials,
if you have to produce videos.
Do you have to buy those
little cameras for your iPhone?
All of those things, all are
part of your equipment costs
and your production
costs, right?
So there's income.
There's revenue.
So that's usually what
comes in from sales
or from contracts, if
you're selling tickets,
if you're selling art,
whatever it may be.
And then profit is
your income, sorry,
profit is your revenue
minus all your costs.
And then what's left over
is hopefully your profit.
This gets tricky with
non-profits, right?
Ideally you spent all
the money and that's
what funders and donors
want to see, right?
If you have money
left over, they're
like, why is there
money left over?
We're not going to
give you more money
until you spend the money
we've already given you, so.
So we'll also go over an
example that deals with that.
But, again, think about
all the different, there's
all the money that comes in.
And it's really important to
track that, because, as I said,
it helps you understand your
sources and uses of funds.
It also helps you understand,
how are you actually allocating
that money, and how can
you show impact, right?
So I think different
sources of income
usually have different,
not usually, but sometimes,
have different impact
metrics requirements, right?
So understanding all
of those things, as you
go into the process,
and also thinking about,
you can work with large funders.
But what are their requirements?
Do they want
quarterly reporting?
semiannual reporting?
Do they want annual
reporting, right?
And all of those
things usually add up
to someone's time on staff.
So if you're a
startup, it's going
to be the entrepreneur's
time and/or maybe
if you're lucky enough to
have a UROP or an intern
or someone like that.
But thinking about all of
those different requirements
and pieces, the other thing
to think about with income,
especially donations
or grants, sometimes
some large organizations also
have attribution requirements.
So they may want to take
credit in terms of their impact
and their reporting for
the things you're doing.
And it's a great way
to get recognition.
It's a great way to
scale but it's also
kind of thinking about
what direction you
want your organization
or your venture to go.
All right, any questions?
One other thing to mention,
depending on where you are
or the organization
granting prize money,
sometimes it can be taxable.
So just especially if you're
an international student,
just beware of any
potential taxation.
Some organizations give
checks or give prize money
to the individual who
entered the competition.
Others might award it
to the organization.
So just be aware
of those things.
All right.
So many years ago, when
I was a graduate student,
I worked for the lending
organization in Oaxaca, Mexico.
And they had an
ecotourism model and they
used that to educate visitors
to Oaxaca about local arts
and the local economy
and the local culture.
And then they also
provided loans
to micro and small
enterprises, most of which
were run by women, either
in the arts, in agriculture,
or running small
businesses like restaurants
and providing services.
So this is sort of what I just
did a very rough budget of what
their operations
looked like, and then
kind of what they did, how
they met their ultimate goal
of supplying loans to artisans.
So these were their three
main sources of income.
So tours, so these
were visits out
to the villages,
donations, so people
who just liked the
organization, and then
they also did some
educational courses.
So you could come and you
could do a cooking course
in the village.
It was a special
day-long activity
And they had two
people on staff.
They had lots of volunteers.
So they had university students
who got volunteer credit
for building out their website,
or for creating a new logo
and that kind of thing.
So they made the most
of those resources.
But these were their actual
staff salary expenditures.
Programs for tourists, so
there was transportation cost
that was pretty much a
fixed cost every month.
And then lunches, which varied
depending on how many people
are on the tour.
And then for courses,
same thing, same fixed
transportation
cost, lunches varied
depending on participation,
and the materials.
So like I said,
if you're cooking
that's all of the ingredients.
If someone's doing weaving,
it's all of the yarn,
and that kind of thing.
And then special
events, so they would
host dinners, small concerts.
Their administration costs,
so marketing was pretty low.
They would just do Facebook
ads, but not too bad, web site,
and then they did staff lunches
for the volunteers every week.
And then whatever was left over,
so all the sources of income,
plus all the expenses
went into this loans
to artisans category, right?
So we talked about non-profit
can be keeping profit
and retained earnings
and all that stuff.
So at the end of the month,
whatever was left over
got converted into loan money.
Because they were non-profit
and not a lending institution,
they could do this.
And so the loans were
basically, if they
got repaid like it
was great, but, you
know, they were not under the
same requirements as a bank
or a financial institution,
Could we do a quick
talk about that, just
a really glancing overview.
I think non-profit can often be
perceived almost as a misnomer.
And, like you were saying,
loans to artisans, things
like that, if you have any
excess income over expenses,
you're allowed to allocate that
pretty much as long as it's
in alignment with the stated
mission of the organization.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for
clarifying that.
Yeah, so that's kind of what
goes back to your non-profit
has a mission, right?
And that's why having
these categories
in these budget
items, so you can
see programs that are offered,
so tours and courses are broken
out, right?
And then administration
applies to all of these.
The executive director
and administrator
work for both of these programs.
And then, at the end, like,
yes, the loans are an expense.
They don't
necessarily come back.
But all of these activities
support this core mission.
And just in some way you
can see different people
maybe outside of this
world would say, Oh, well,
those are just
basically charity.
And like, yes and no, and that's
more of a philosophical debate.
But I think the point is
that there was clarity.
There's transparency in what
the organization was doing.
So all of those things
are really important.
This was a 501 (3) (c)
registered in the United States
with operations in Mexico.
So you have the ability to
collect these funds from donors
in the US and then
administer them
in accord with the stated
mission and purpose.
So, yeah.
So, I mean, there are lots
of different ways to do this.
You may not be doing
that, or you may not
be facilitating a
lending program.
But just thinking about,
that's really the purpose
is you're creating value and
how are you sharing that value.
So, yeah, and I worked in a
hybrid organization as well.
So if anybody does have a
hybrid they're thinking about,
we can talk more
about that offline.
But, yeah, there are a lot
of different ways to do this.
So just a couple of things,
one thing I think that applies,
and this goes back to
sustainability very
much to for-profit and
non-profit startups,
is that, at the
beginning, you will
be maximizing the talents
of the individuals who
work in your
organization, to really
be playing to their strengths.
As your business starts
to grow, then you'll
find you need to look
for individuals who
have more specific strengths.
Usually you're looking for
more senior managers, or maybe
a highly specialized skill set.
And so just thinking
about, as you
start to allocate those expenses
and those salaries, right,
so you may have someone
who does something,
that teaches a very
specific course,
or is an expert in
something that has
to do with tours or marketing.
So again, just thinking
about, but once you
have these categories
you can then
make a decision about how
the people spend their time
or how equipment and
different resources
are used in the organization.
Income is almost always the
easiest part to figure out.
You have money
coming in, hopefully
it's going into one
of these categories.
This stuff can get a
little bit trickier,
and as your organization grows
the categories may change.
So this particular organization
looked at transportation.
And after a time
they realized, hey,
we're actually better off if
we buy our own van, right?
This is a recurring
expense, and there
are a lot of things
that we could
do if we didn't have this lump
sum every month going out.
So those are things
that are really useful.
The other thing is to recognize
there's seasonality, right?
So down here they are a
really lean organization,
and they could just make
loans to artisans every month.
But you might have a
month that's negative,
and the next month is positive.
And then you balance that out
at the end of the quarter,
or the end of the year, or
whatever your tax situation is.
And there's seasonality, right?
July and August you
have a lot of tourists.
Or July you have
a lot, August you
have a lot in the beginning,
not so many in the end,
and then in September, you have
a bunch of retired teachers
who love to travel.
In September, I mean,
that was the seasonality
of this business, right?
So we always know we'll
get a bump up in September.
All right, any
questions at this point?
All right.
One thing is, especially
if you're a startup,
and this applies to
for-profit and non-profit,
if you have early
clients or people who
are interested in what you're
doing, ask them to fund this.
You don't have to say, will
you fund my first project.
But you can say,
we need a deposit,
or we need 50% upfront, right?
So figure out what your
costs are or what you need.
And maybe you really
need that Adobe license.
And you shouldn't
right now, because you
can get it for free from MIT.
But maybe you really
need something.
You need a camera.
You need a technology license.
And you don't have
to say to the client,
will you give me the money
to buy this technology,
or I need the money upfront
for this technology license.
But you can use your budget
and you can use your expenses,
and you can say, OK, this is
a fair deposit price, right?
We're asking for 50% upfront.
But again having a
budget is a good way,
it's also great when
you start to fundraise.
If you need $1,000 and someone
says, we can give you $500,
what can you do with that?
Then you can say, OK,
these are the things
that are nice to have, and
then these are the things
that we absolutely need,
to be able to move forward
and produce this, right?
But having that knowledge
and information,
and being able to put
those project budget
expenses in an appendix if
somebody asks to see them,
definitely gives
you an advantage.
All right.
So we can spend a
little bit of time,
so fundraising, obviously,
MIT is a fantastic environment
for grants and prizes,
anything that's
non-dilutive or isn't incurring
any debt is fantastic.
And also use that,
this is a great time
to focus on the
sustainability of your models.
So any non-profit that's
successful long term
has some kind of sustainability
into their operations,
and has clients who find value
in what they're doing, right?
Always evaluate whether your
mission aligns with that
of your funders and donors.
We're at a time where
it's really apparent why
we need to do this, also
at a time where it's
easier than ever to do this.
So there are a lot of tools
out there to evaluate.
People are pretty honest now
through all kinds of mediums.
But just make sure that what
you are doing is aligned
and that you're not going
to be experiencing mission
drift or things like that.
Consider reporting
requirements and attribution.
So I've heard from different
non-profits, maybe not
necessarily in the arts,
that sometimes getting
a little bit of money from
a really big name donor can
actually be very burdensome.
So really think about what the
value of that relationship is,
beyond just a
donation or grants.
Make sure, especially with
grants now, some of them
can be recoverable grants.
So those that would be income
coming into your budget,
that would also
be something that
lies on your balance sheet
and your financial statement.
So if you take
off in five years,
some organizations can
say, hey, remember us?
We gave you your
first big grant.
So just keep those
things in mind.
They're great.
But as you start to track
all of your sources of income
and your expenses, don't
lose sight of that.
One thing is, this is tricky
with measuring and evaluating
the impact of what you're doing.
You should, especially
at the early stages,
have some kind of key
metrics that you're
tracking and defining, right?
So that's one thing that
really sets non-profits apart,
and for-profit
ventures do it as well.
But I think you can really,
if you can demonstrate
the impact of what
you're doing, and if you
have good metrics that make
sense, funders and donors will
be more likely to work with you.
There are lists, so you can go
to the global impact investing
network.
There are all kinds of lists
and frameworks out there
for impact.
But just make sure
that you're choosing
what makes sense for you.
And I think it's OK to start
with some basic things.
And then you can start to
think about things that
might be more of a stretch.
So maybe they're difficult
to measure right now,
or you're not doing them.
But you can also
use those to set
goals for your organization.
Shannon?
I think that's an
incredibly good point.
A lot of the value added,
I think, of the 15K,
compared to some of
the other contests,
is that we do a sort of emphasis
on storytelling and narrative
and qualitative points,
because a lot of the arts,
it can be a little trickier
to nail down some quant data,
but quant data benchmarks,
impact evaluation,
are incredibly important
for ongoing viability
and sustainability.
So even if you're
perfecting your pitch
and perfecting your
talking points,
you've also still got to be
able to show that it's working.
And you need to know
how you're going
to measure that it's working,
so incredibly important.
That and along getting any
kind of client testimonial
is really, really important.
Yeah, so anything
you can do to have
that kind of qualitative feature
as well as that quantitative
is great.
There's a journalist, she
was a journalist in residence
with the Legatum Center.
Unfortunately COVID hit
and she had to go home
to Alexandria, Virginia.
But she does write a lot
about local entrepreneurs
all over the US.
She has a website called
Times of Entrepreneurship.
And so she also lists local
resources for entrepreneurs.
When I say local, I mean in
different regions of the US.
But she's a great person.
And if you're doing
something really cool,
it's worth following her
and like raising your hand
on Twitter or whatever,
and saying, hey, I'm
doing this cool thing that's
providing jobs for artisans
in the US, or
creating a platform,
or getting recognition for
what they're doing, right?
So also I think we're in a time
now where everything's online.
But I've also seen people
make really great connections,
whether to funders or
donors or just key talent,
by using those
different channels that
are available to you.
I think that the adage
of you ask for advice
and you get money, and you ask
for money and you get advice,
probably applies
across the board.
So a few other things
on fundraising,
think about if you
have co-founders,
think about your
relationship with them,
how everyone is
contributing to the team,
and what each team
member's goals are.
So that's really
important as you
start to think about growing
or scaling or what's next.
The structure, so right now
you might be a non-profit,
but in five years it might
make sense to be a hybrid.
Or you might find
that, and this happened
when I was at Root
Capital, what's
considered a non-profit
operation in the US
is considered a for-profit
operation somewhere else.
So being prepared
to adapt and, again,
that goes back to what is your
mission, what is your goal,
and who's either funding
you, investing you,
or supporting you.
Yeah, so I think
that's about it.
Any questions, any
thoughts on fundraising?
All right.
Good luck.
So feel free to reach
out with questions.
This is a general,
high-level overview.
But if anyone does have
more specific questions
or would like to
talk through anything
or additional resources,
I'm fine if you
want to reach out via email.
Awesome.
We have a couple of questions,
if you don't mind some Q&A now.
Does that work?
Yeah.
That works.
So you hit on something
about budgeting
for operating,
budgeting for expenses.
And I was sort of
thinking that there's
a lot of baggage
surrounding the sort
of lean non-profit mentality.
And that really negatively
impacts specifically arts
driven non-profit orgs.
So like how, is there
any more specificity
you can give about
recommending budgeting
for general ops
and other expenses,
in case you have
donors who strongly
prefer that their funds
be restricted exclusively
to program use?
Yeah, that's really challenging.
And I think one of the things
that can help entrepreneurs
with that is going back to
this impact metrics, right?
So if you show that,
to deliver a program,
you have to have space, right?
You can't, well,
hopefully, we're
returning to a
non-COVID world, right?
So right now like
renting an office space
may be hard to justify.
But if you're thinking
like we actually
need a space, because we
have a program and people,
for example, need to
be close to a T, right?
So if you're running an
arts program for children
after school, they
need to be close.
They probably need to be close
to a certain location, right?
There's a convenience
element there.
And I think having understanding
for whom you're providing
services and what are the
true costs that go into that,
and the value of what
you're doing, can help.
And some funders might, I want
to say, dig in their heels.
They might be more resistant.
One thing to be aware of is that
sometimes large organizations,
especially, have one set
of grant requirements.
And they will just make
all of the requirements
the same for all of their
receiving organizations.
And I think that's where having
a really good program officer,
having a good
relationship is key.
The other thing, too, is
there are some funders who
understand that.
And they're willing
to fund those things.
And I think being savvy
in your fundraising
and finding several
good partners,
and some who it's
like, hey, we have
these operational expenses,
and we have to cover them.
In terms of your
reporting, you know
you have to record your
expenses on your books, right?
So every time you have to
buy posterboard or paperclips
or copier paper,
all of those things
are line items on your books.
But in terms of your
administrative expenses,
you can also use
categories to say,
these are the things
we're doing, right?
So you don't have
funders who are
looking at like
every time you bought
Kind bars for the office.
But it's like--
You know, 'cause the
lights need to stay on,
you need toilet paper
in the bathroom.
Right.
But I think if you
can also find ways,
and this is where you go back
to allocating those expenses,
right?
If you have multiple
donors or funders,
it's like, well, you know,
30% of our electric bill
went to this program,
because we ran classes
for three days a week
for a whole semester.
And that's what you
need to do that.
So relationships are tricky.
But you can manage them.
And when I've seen those kinds
of things managed successfully,
it's because everyone has
very good information,
good information that allows
them to demonstrate that,
yes, we needed these kinds of
operational overhead things,
but this is how they directly
contributed to the program.
And I think saying we're
not charging 100% of this
to this program, right, if
you have the flexibility
to do that.
We're charging this 30%, because
the program you're funding
is 30% of all of our operations.
Perfect.
Thank you.
One piece of insight that may
be helpful for students watching
this asynchronously
or students now.
What do you see as the
most common mistake
that first time founders,
students, typically
make with budgets, and
what would your advice
be to correct that
or get ahead of that?
I think one thing I see, and
I talked to this already,
is people not
valuing their time.
And so I think we talked about
different ways to benchmark
that.
So making sure that that's been
accounted for somehow, as you
look forward to what
it would actually
cost to run your business,
or to run your organization
as a business.
I think the other thing,
too, is just all the smaller
things add up, right?
And you just don't
think about it.
And so I would say really just
tracking all of the expenses
and all of the things that
you need to do in a day.
So as students you have tons
of resources available to you.
But as I said, and I've seen
this when students graduate,
it's the Adobe
license that you need.
Or it's you're no longer at
MIT and so if something happens
to your computer, you can't
just go to IS&T and drop it off,
right?
You know, that's a real thing.
So knowing like I need a $2,500
computer to create this design
or to do my work or
to have the editing
equipment or the video
equipment that I need.
Really being cognizant
of all those equipment
costs that maybe you haven't
incurred since you started
the venture, but
these are real things
that you need every
day to do that.
Excellent.
I think maybe one or two more.
I don't want to overstay
our welcome or anything.
You're not overstaying.
So how does one sort of
anticipate creating balance.
How do you safely
assess risk when
you're attempting
to forecast things
like revenue versus
expenses, especially
in a startup that has
few, if any, guarantees
of upfront financing?
Yeah.
So I think as we've
seen in the last year,
even the best plans can go,
so one thing I will say,
during COVID, I've
spoken with funders
of all kinds of
different industries,
and the common theme
has been, we're
no longer looking at performance
for the last year, right?
The only thing
that really matters
is what companies have
done in the last six months
to three months, right?
And the ability to pivot or
to use whatever resources
are available to solve a
problem and move forward
has become much more
important in terms
of making a decision about whom
or what to back or to fund.
So I think to that point we're
in a chaotic environment.
I think understanding
what expenses and factors
you might be able
to control, and what
might be beyond your
control, and just
being very upfront about
that, and having backup plans.
I mean you can do
sensitivity analyses, right?
So I've worked in
non-profits where
we had to do this because we
didn't know what was going
to happen to a currency
or an interest rate
in the local market.
And so you can
actually do those.
Excel is a wonderful tool.
It's not wonderful, it's
not always wonderful.
But it has the
ability to allow you
to copy your spreadsheets over.
You can do those forecasts,
and you can say, hey,
nobody can come
to our performance
because there's a
pandemic, but look
at what other people are doing.
Are there other
performance models
and what are our alternatives?
And being able to say, OK,
under these circumstances,
we think we can
still make this work.
Perfect.
That's a great piece of advice.
And building on that, thinking
about this competition
more broadly, if you could
think back on the business
that you've seen
and participated in,
if you have one pearl
of wisdom or takeaway
for students competing in this
competition, what would that
be?
I would say, really
focus on your story
and why you are the
right person to lead
this venture at this time.
I think anyone wants
to feel like you're
going to do this
regardless of where you
land in the competition, right?
That just underscored exactly
what we're trying to do here.
We're trying to be
good storytellers.
And, you know, we're trying
not to be so end-game driven.
It's really great if you walk
away with the great big check,
but it's also pretty great
if you learn anything
from these workshops, from the
mentorship, from the feedback.
So ideally everybody tells a
better story when they come out
than when they came in.
So thank you for that.
So, yeah.
So it's really about telling
the story of the world you're
trying to build, and
then having people want
to join you on your journey.
Perfect.
This has been fantastic.
I really appreciate your
time and the insights
and thank you so much.